[Music]  Abby Lee Miller out of the big house and  off to God's house I'm throat just days  after being released from prison the  former Dance Moms star was spotted in  Los Angeles on Sunday attending an  Easter service at church the 51 year old  reality star flashed a thumbs up on her  way inside  she looked chic in a sparkly black  ensemble with shiny hoop earrings but  her best accessory that big smile it's  wonderful after pleading guilty to  bankruptcy fraud in June Abby was  sentenced to one year and one day in  federal prison she was released last  Tuesday completing eight and a half  months of her sentence and now it seems  she's focused on getting back to her  everyday life on Thursday Abby was  spotted enjoying some me time  getting a mani-pedi at an LA nail salon  [Music]  [Applause]